Well hello there!
You caught me while
I was working out.
Last time I was lifting weights
during a Crash Course episode,
also...the last time
I was lifting weights.
We were talking about
how all of this is possible
because of cellular respiration,
the process our cells use
to get and store energy
from the food that we eat.
Remember that?
Good times.
As it happens, a lot
of what we learned then
is also really helpful in
understanding the organ system
that we use to do our
gun-blasting and walking
and fork-and-knife
operating, and parkour
and playing Assassin's Creed
and you know, like, moving around.
I'm talking about
your muscles of course,
and you wouldn't be able
to move them without the help
of the same molecule that your cells
use to get all their jobs done.
Good old adenosine triphosphate.
Now, your muscles may be your
body's most obvious moving parts,
but as with all things that
are truly worth learning about,
this system is both way more
complex and way more awesome
than it first appears.
YEAH!
Why? Because of chemistry.
When you think of muscles,
your mind usually goes straight
to the guns there. But you
really have three different types
of muscle in your body.
You have the cardiac muscle.
Your heart muscle, which is
different from all the other
sorts of muscle in your body.
And then you have smooth
muscle, which is responsible
for carrying out most
of your involuntary processes,
like pushing food
through your digestive tract
and pushing blood
through your arteries.
Important stuff there.
And then there's the muscles
that you're most familiar with:
the skeletal muscles.
Your gluteus maximus.
Your masseter, which is important
for chewing your hot pockets.
And your abductor pollicis brevis,
right at the base of your thumb
aka your "video game muscles"
That's important for
the Assassin's Creed.
Just some of the 640
skeletal muscles you have.
Those muscles,
like all of your muscles,
are only good at two things:
contracting to become shorter
and relaxing back out
to their resting length.
That's all muscles do,
they contract, and they relax,
it's pretty amazing that you
can make a ballerina out of that...
If you were to peel back my skin
and take a look at one of my muscles
Please don't do that,
but if you did...
You'd see that it
thickens in the middle,
at what's called the muscle belly,
and then tapers off on
either end into a tendon.
Tendons are made of fibrous
proteins, mostly collagen,
that connect the muscle to the bone.
Just a side note, ligaments
are similar to tendons,
but instead they connect
bones to other bones.
These muscle-tendon combos
stretch across one or more joints
in this case, it
stretches across my elbow
so that one bone can move
in relation to the other bone.
So I just moved my arm and
now I'm moving my mouth,
and I'm basically moving
my whole body right now,
and the question is:
how am I doing this?
How am I moving all of these things
in all of these amazing, fluid ways?
How am I able to do that at all?
Unfortunately, it's kind of
complicated, but it's wonderful
and amazing so it will
be worth it in the end.
First we need to understand
the anatomy of a skeletal muscle,
which includes many, many
layers of long, thin strands.
Think of one of your
skeletal muscles as a rope.
It's made of smaller
ropes that are bundled together,
and those ropes are
made of bundles of thread,
and those threads are
made of tiny, tiny filaments.
This structure is what
makes meat stringy,
because after all,
meat is just muscle.
This chicken breast is,
or was, the pectoralis major
muscle of a chicken.
It connected the bird's sternum
or breastbone to the humerus
in its wing, and sometimes I
feel like chickens have
bigger pecs than I do.
This is crazy.
When you peel this muscle
apart, you see that it's really
made up of layers of thin strings.
These are muscle fascicles,
and each fascicle is made up of
lots and lots of much smaller
strands, these we can't see.
They're called muscle fibers and
these are the actual muscle cells.
Now, because muscle cells
perform such a specialized job,
they're not like your
run-of-the-mill somatic cells.
For starters, they each
have multiple nuclei.
That's because each muscle
cell is actually formed
by a bunch of cells,
somewhat like stem-cells,
called progenitor cells,
fusing together.
Muscle cells are basically just
bundles of complex protein strands,
and since nuclei are essential
for the protein-making process,
muscle cells need lots of nuclei
to make all the protein they need.
From here on you'll notice,
by the way, that a lot of the stuff
I'm talking about start
with the prefixes myo- and sarco-,
from the Greek words for
muscle or flesh, respectively.
Whenever you see
those terms in biology,
you know you're probably
in muscle country.
For instance, those protein
strands that I just mentioned
that make up a muscle
cell are called myofibrils.
And each one is divided lengthwise
into segments called sarcomeres.
This is where the
action happens, my friends,
because it's the sarcomere that
will actually do the contracting
and relaxing to create
the muscle movement.
Each muscle cell has tens
of thousands of these guys,
and they all contract
together to make you do stuff.
And this contracting and relaxing
occurs through this really cool
and complex interaction between
two different kinds of protein
strands called myofilaments.
One myofilament is the protein
actin, which are skinny strands
that attach to either one of
the two ends of the sarcomere.
And the other is myosin,
which is thicker and studded
with these little golf-club
shaped knobs along it called heads.
Inside a sarcomere,
these proteins occur in layers,
with the thick strand of myosin
floating between several
strands of actin.
Just how many strands of
actin depends on the muscle
we're talking about.
In this case, let's just
say that there are four:
two sitting on top,
and two sitting on the bottom.
Now, when the muscle
cell is at rest,
none of these strands
are touching each other,
but they really,
desperately want to!
They're like middle school
students at a formal dance.
The myosin in particular wants
nothing more than to reach
its little heads up and do some
heavy petting with the actin.
The chemical dance that
allows this to happen
is one of the sexiest things
that goes on in your body
other than, like, sex
and it's known as the sliding
filament model of muscle contraction.
Which reminds me of
an interesting story ...
I mentioned last week that
we didn't really have even
a passing understanding of the
human skeleton until the 1500s,
which seems kind of tardy
to the party to me.
But that's nothing
compared with this:
we didn't figure out how
muscles worked until 1954!
In 1954, two teams of researchers
independently discovered
that the sliding filament
model is how muscles contract.
And, as luck would have it,
two of the four scientists
who made this discovery
were named Huxley.
We've already discussed
Thomas Henry Huxley,
the father of comparative anatomy,
and Darwin's Bulldog.
Well, his grandkids were all
awesome at something, too,
like Aldous Huxley, who wrote
the novel Brave New World;
Julian Huxley, who was
central to the development of
modern evolutionary theory;
and Andrew Fielding Huxley.
Andrew Huxley was
a physiologist who
with colleague Rolf Niedergerke
set out to solve
the muscle-contracting mystery.
Until the early 1950's all
we knew was that myofibrils
were full of protein strands.
At the time, most people
thought that these strands
simply changed shape and shortened,
like how a spring recoils
after its been stretched out.
And by the '50s, we'd
learned pretty much everything
we could about muscle cells
by using conventional microscopes.
So Huxley and Niedergerke
actually designed and built
a new microscope.
A tricked out kind of
an interference microscope,
which uses two separate
beams of light.
And with that, they found
that during contraction,
some protein strands kept
their lengths the same,
while others around
them contracted.
But at the very same time,
British biophysicist Jean Hanson,
and Hugh Esmor Huxley, an American
biologist who had no relation
to the famous British Huxleys,
were using another new-fangled
tool, the electron microscope.
Using that, they observed
that muscle fiber
was composed of those
thick and thin filaments
the myosin and the actin
and that the filaments were
arranged in such a way
that they could slide across each
other to shorten the sarcomere.
So in two separate papers published
the same day in the same journal,
the two teams proposed that
muscle contractions were caused
by the movement of one
protein over another.
I guess, an idea
whose time had come.
Except it's not that simple.
To understand how the
sliding filament model works,
the first thing to
keep in mind is that,
in addition to needing
a bunch of protein,
muscle cells need to
make lots of ATP.
ATP, you remember, creates the
energy for almost everything
your body does. Yes, that goes
for muscle movement as well.
Another thing to remember is that
some proteins can change shape
when they come into
contact with certain ions
like we've seen that with the
sodium potassium pumps, for instance.
Those pumps are proteins that can
accept sodium ions outside a cell
and then they change shape
to release them inside a cell,
and also suddenly at the same time
become able to accept potassium ions.
These shape-changers are how
cells get a lot of the
day-to-day job of living done.
In a sarcomere, it's calcium
ions that change the shape
of some of the proteins, so
that the myosin can finally
have its way and grope the
actin strands all around it.
Then it'll drag those actin
strands toward each other,
causing the sarcomere to contract.
But when the muscle
cell is at rest,
there are a couple of things that
keep this groping from happening.
The first is a set of two
proteins wrapped around the actin.
They're called
tropomyosin and troponin,
and together they act
as a kind of insulation.
Let's just continue
our middle school metaphor.
They're the chaperones that
protect the actin from groping.
At this point, each little
head on the myosin strand
has the wreckage of a spent
ATP molecule stuck to it
that's an ADP and a phosphate
and the energy from that
broken ATP is already stored
inside the head.
So yeah, the myosin has a
lot of pent-up...frustration.
While the muscle cell is resting,
it's preparing a stockpile of
calcium ions that it will use
as a trigger when it's go-time.
This is done by a specialized
version of the smooth endoplasmic
reticulum, called the
sarcoplasmic reticulum or SR.
It's wrapped around each sarcomere
and it's studded
with calcium pumps.
These pumps are constantly
burning up ATP to create
a high concentration of
calcium inside the SR.
And of course, whenever you
create a concentration gradient,
You know it's gonna get used.
So now we're ready for a
muscle contraction to start,
but what starts it?
Well, stimulus,
of course, from a neuron.
Muscles are activated
by motor neurons,
and each sarcomere has
a motor neuron nearby.
When a signal travels down the
neuron to the neuron's synapse
with the muscle cell, it triggers
a release of neurotransmitters,
which in turn set off
another action potential
inside the muscle cell.
That action potential continues
along the muscle cell's membrane,
and then flows inside
it along special folds
in the membrane called t-tubules.
When that signal reaches the
SR inside the cell, bingo.
The SR's channels open wide
and let all the calcium ions
diffuse down that
concentration gradient.
The calcium ions bind with one
of the chaperones to the troponin
which causes the troponin
to rotate around the actin
and drag the tropomyosin
out of the way,
revealing all of those super-hot
binding sites on the actin.
With our chaperones
distracted, the myosin...
it totally goes to town.
It reaches all of those little
tiny heads along its length
to bind up with the actin, and the
excitement of that long-awaited,
precious contact finally
releases the energy
that came from breaking
that ATP molecule.
This burst of energy causes
the heads to suddenly bend
toward the center of the sarcomere,
pulling the actin strands
together, and
shrinking the sarcomere.
In millions of sarcomeres in hundreds
of thousands of muscle cells,
this is what allows
me to, like, lift my arms.
You wouldn't think it
would be so complicated.
Now, in order for
the contraction to stop,
you're gonna have to
tear those two proteins apart.
Because each myosin head
is really comfortable here,
snuggling with its beloved actin.
It'll take another passing ATP
molecule to attach to the head,
which breaks off one of the
phosphates to release its energy
as soon as they touch.
That energy breaks the
myosin's bond with the actin
and lowers the head, leaving it
alone and frustrated once more.
So, it's weird, that the
energy from the Atp
is actually used to
make the muscle relax.
But in fact, that's
why we get rigor mortis.
When you're dead there's no more
ATP to make the muscle relax
and all the calcium ions diffuse
out of the sarcoplasmic reticulum
causing the muscles enter their
resting state...which is contracted.
But, you're not dead yet,
so let's wrap this up.
While the myosin and actin
are being separated,
the sarcoplasmic reticulum is hard
at work pumping all of the calcium
ions back inside it and
storing them up for next time.
That lets our chaperones come back,
the troponin and tropomyosin
retake their positions
around the actin strands,
and resets the sarcomere
for the next impulse to come along.
Chemistry makes it all possible!
From blasting your guns to,
my awesome dance moves.
Thank you for watching this
episode of Crash Course Biology.
If you want to go back
and look at some stuff,
because it was a confusing
episode today: table of contents!
And thanks to everyone
who helped put this together,
this one was a doozy.
So thanks to our head writer,
Blake de Pastino.
And of course, Amber, as always,
for doing our amazing graphics.
If you have any questions,
please leave them down below
in the comments, or get in touch
with us on Facebook or Twitter.
We will endeavor to answer you,
as will all of those
extraordinarily helpful people who
are not affiliated with us at all,
but are quite smart and helpful.
So thank you to them.
And we'll see you next time.